red is everywhere this time of year and
if you've always wanted to rock a red
lip like taylor swift don't be scared
it's easy to rock that classic look and
here to give us some pointers is denise
dixon the owner of the cosmotology
institute of las vegas and ariana tyler
a student there welcome we also have our
beautiful model megan
tell us denise a little bit about the
cosmetology institute and what people
can learn there well the cosmetology
institute is located in north las vegas
on west craig road and we do offer all
programs hair skin and nails now if you
are you can start at any age really you
can be
finishing up a career and deciding to
want to do something new or you could be
fresh out of high school and do it right
absolutely you can start as early as the
11th grade
all the way up until you feel like you
still have those skills you want to go
through oh man and you can that can
really take you a lot of places
it's it's great to see so many success
stories coming out of the las vegas
cosmetology scene and i'm sure that
you're a big contributor to that
absolutely we love it let's talk about
the red lip ariana you are a student
there how how has it been for you that's
been amazing it's just a humbling
experience to be able to do what i love
and to be around in the industry where
everybody is just passionate creative
and it's really a fun time it doesn't
really feel like school it just feels
like comfortable and fun well if your
makeup is any indication on how well
you've not learned there
i mean a plus you you have definitely
passed in my book let's talk about the
red lip a lot of people are intimidated
by it uh as you can tell i'm wearing
pink because i'm intimidated by us tell
us some tips and tricks on that well so
a few tips is just feeling comfortable
and making sure that you have a good lip
liner usually there's always a lot of
bleeding that happens but when you make
sure that you line the lip properly just
right around your natural lip line it's
going to actually help build a base for
it for it not to bleed and then you want
to just kind of get used to it now a lot
of people will line on the outside of
the lip just to get that fuller look do
you recommend that with red i do
recommend that with red because it's
going to help your teeth look a lot
lighter and it's going to give you a
better shape of your look and your lips
okay let's talk about the color red with
different skin tones what do we have on
megan today on megan right now we do
have a vibrant um very vintage red with
uh also a slightly like a shade darker
around her lip line it's gonna give a
more voluminous lip it's gonna plump it
out just because it's giving dimension
around the outside and into the middle
now i notice that you and denise also
have the red lips you guys are very
matte she looks a little more shimmery
what's big for the season
is red always in season red's a classic
look and everybody can find the red that
they like with megan because her lips
are so beautiful and she has a beautiful
cupid's bow i do love like the little
glossy moment so the satin of the
lipstick that we chose today is gonna
actually gonna build it plump and for
miss denise and i we do like a matte
look with a darker
ridge and more ombre effect with the red
so it's all about playing around with
what you like what you feel most
comfortable with and what makes you feel
most beautiful because the red lip is
very very beautiful on every woman and
everyone should try it is there a brand
that is good for everyone no matter what
your skin tone is you have to play with
it right i'm going to say inglot
inglot red lip it's going to be matte
and it goes great with all skin tones
but it's all about the lip liner that's
actually going to be able to adjust
towards all skin tones of women great
advice ladies thank you so much for
joining us man i got some learning to do
all right jillian over to you
well our day